[Music]
we're delighted to be joined now by the
one and only there's only one of her
drew barrymore she is of course host of
the drew barrymore show it's right here
by the way on cbs drew is really letting
her audiences in this season on her life
on tomorrow's show for instance she
opens up about her experience dating as
a single mom and speaks with queer eye
star that's bobby burke about the best
place to host a zoom date bobby got
ideas
if you really are out there looking for
you know if you're looking for a hook-up
great girl start that from the bedroom
but if you're if you're yeah if you are
like hey i'm looking i want this to
possibly be a relationship don't start
it from the bedroom don't have your bed
in the background that's great advice
like it's sending a real
sort of sex forward message
and i am um
[Music]
not ready for that
[Music]
i don't know how to date with kids you
know i'm not there yet i have two young
girls and i'm like
i don't want to bring people home i
think that it would take me a very long
time to meet someone and get to know
them before i could even ever introduce
them to my daughters and and i don't
think anybody knows how to do anything
right so don't put that pressure on
yourself that you don't know how to do
it i think going into it saying to
yourself i don't know how to do it it's
the first step of figuring out how to do
it because it's those people that go in
like i know what i'm doing i got this
you know what it's not going to affect
my kids what i do like
you're thinking about that and you're
thinking how it's going to affect them
and you're being careful about it which
means you're a good mom oh my god that
you're an amazing mother don't don't
question that at all
i agree with you bobby burke drew
barrymore don't question that about
yourself at all i've seen you with your
kids frankie and all i get it i get it
but where did the emotion come from
because you're talking and you're fine
yeah is it sometimes when you start
saying the words out loud all of a
sudden it hits you
you know i got ready with bobby tan
anthony and jonathan the queer
i'm such a queer-eye fan yeah and
i had never realized
and said out loud that
i don't know how to date with kids my
kid's dad is happily remarried with the
most wonderful woman in the world ali my
children have this extraordinary stepmom
and our processes have been different
and their side of the street is so
functional and whole and happening and i
think i've been on the sidelines
in a beautiful honoring purgatory
and
saying it out loud i've been saying that
it's me it's my choice
you know i'm not ready i want to wait
i don't think i said out loud that it's
really because of i have these two
daughters you really want to and you
don't know how how old are your
daughters now seven and nine so i've
been single for six years and i just
have honestly really not have known how
to do this i'll go on an occasional date
but that's only in the last like two
years it took me four to even step out
there
and people have different processes
then enter a pandemic when you think
maybe i should step out of my comfort
zone and even see
um i also think it's different for women
too drew with young daughters i think
it's young children i think that that's
very different difficult so what what
what have you decided what have you
decided how are you navigating it you
know i also honestly found zoom dates um
really unromantic
they're just a reminder
they're a reminder to me of the state of
the world we're living in however
point counterpoint
you can't fight city hall online dating
is where it's at
this is not a bad editing process i've
had a few in-person dates that i would
have given anything for them to be on
zoom
and
i'm like okay i'm ready to this is queer
eye x drew barrymore show x kind of new
york times modern love there's a secret
recipe that's happening in this episode
that is vulnerable and about all of us
how do we date in the modern world and
navigate family and life and romance and
virtual and pandemic
and really it's about
so much of the episode is really about
talking to these wonderful men who go
out there and i'm no different than any
of their other clients
we're trying to get into our bravery
it's as simple as that it seems like you
know what you don't want to do when it
comes to your kids
however you're working out what you do
want when it comes to a partner so what
are you looking for can you say at this
point in a relationship definitely um
someone who isn't interested in marriage
or kids um
did you ask that on the first zoom call
you know i don't even talk about my kids
uh actually because i think that we
probably have to get to know each other
first although i would love to know
right out of the gate if kids were
non-negotiable for them that would be
that would be good to know up front
check great moving on
but i don't talk about them because i'm
so protective of them
that it makes me feel vulnerable to
discuss them i have to know you a little
bit better and have some trust
in order to even discuss so you're not
looking to get married again oh god
never really no oh you say that now no i
agree
that now no no no there's no reason to
be i can i would maybe live with someone
again maybe
but i've had kids and um there's no way
i will never ever ever ever it's like
you've been on that roller coaster ride
already we're gonna save this tape nate
i will never ever ever ever i would like
to start i think there's a several
billion dollar cottage industry called a
promise ceremony out there
that negates legality yeah and goes out
for the weekend with all your friends
and the plans and the food trucks and
the fantasies and the i love you
profession
professionals of what is the word i'm
looking for like
declaration thank you your love in front
of your friends because that's also
missing yeah out of and i never will get
married again that's called an
anniversary
topic maybe i should introduce you to my
older brother who's single uh he coaches
for the minnesota timberwolves he he
said to me years ago this is kind of
like oh wow he said he was going to
start a website um called don't get
married.com because he is like it's not
necessary if you don't need to get
married that's a separate conversation
i'm joking but you mentioned bravery
though um some people say if you're
scared of heights go bungee jump yep if
you have aquaphobia jump in the water
yes for people at home that have
hesitation that are unsure about
themselves
throwing themselves into the dating
scene and is it that simple just jumping
into the water is that the advice you
would give
and also having the ability to sit with
the queer eye crew and realize that this
is not just about me being stuck
that this is about when you're a single
mom
it's a dynamic that i have probably not
been able to figure out yet
and that's okay to have patience with
ourselves i think it's good that you're
sharing it i think it's really good i
think it will help a lot of people i'm a
single mom too mine are 35 and 34.
that's why i wanted to talk very much